using an app to show you're vast it's
technology that many in las vegas will
soon have right on their phones thank
you for joining us tonight at 11 i'm
brian loftis and i'm denise valdez the
raiders are using the clear app to check
fans vaccination status for games at
allegiant stadium arko mana joining us
now live to show us how it works orca
well niece and brian a whole lot of
people will be using the clear app here
at allegiant stadium you can easily
download it onto your smartphone you
create a health pass and then you can
also add a digital vaccine card all it
takes is a few photos and a few clicks
as well
and
experts we asked them how effective it
actually is based on biometric data a
high-tech tool to verify your
vaccination status to start using the
clear apps health pass you take a
picture of your id and then snap a
selfie scans your face and make sure you
are who you actually say you are you'll
upload an image of your covid vaccine
card and then manually verify that same
information the resulting qr code is
what you use to get into an event that
requires proof of vaccination we have
image recognition technology that looks
at the card itself to make sure that it
it fits the
what a valid cdc card is they've made it
as simple as you can agilitec it
president alan hockson tells me the app
is much better than showing a physical
vaccination card but unfortunately there
are going to be some people that are
going to abuse that system to get around
the requirements i think a database a
national database is going to be the
next step to
improve the process the las vegas
raiders are using the clear app for
games at allegiant stadium those we
spoke to are ready to use it i for sure
feel comfortable putting my information
on a app especially if it means not
wearing a mask we use our cell phones a
lot nowadays so i think it would be more
convenient for that reason hawkson says
i would expect any large public event to
follow what the raiders
have done
[Applause]
and here's an interesting note when you
showed that qr code the background
actually moves so when you present it to
enter an event you can show that you're
actually using the app and that it's not
a screenshot reporting live at
allegiance stadium tonight orca mana 8
news now